this final episode
perhaps final episode of what we want to
say about the whole bletchley park story
it's got a very personal touch for me
because this one is triggered
by that question that all sons and
daughters ask of their parents their mom
or their dad
and i certainly did i said to my dad dad
what did you do in the war
and i got the reply and always did
um
codes and cyphers son it's absolutely
top secret still i mean this was in the
1950s 60s i was asking can't tell you
about it sorry
my dad was not actually at bletchley
park
but he was what was called a cipher
sergeant and he received summarized
decrypts from bletchley park and it was
his job
the place he was posted raf station or
naval station to take the decrypts under
most secure conditions to the person in
charge who knew about what was called
the ultra secret he had to have full
security clearance and my dad did as
well so i'd like to tell you that story
but perhaps we ought to lead up to it a
bit more chronologically and get you
there in stages
we left the story last time in 1941 42
even the four rotor naval enigma could
just about be got on top of
the army and air force one really from
about 42 onwards was not too much
trouble so you've got these decrypts and
they're all wonderful and they're giving
you all of this intelligence how on
earth you get it out into the field to
the commanders that need it
fast enough if you think about it it
would come in you know that the uh the
code settings are going to be changing
another 12 hours time
you'll have to work those out you let
the
the techies the boffins as they call
them in in those days get on with that
but what about the intelligence
community behind them hurt three and had
four i think were two of the big
intelligence huts at bletchley park and
their job was to take
um all of the decrypts and see what they
meant and try to synthesize them put
them all together decide who should get
what
try to make some sense out of it because
you know sometimes if a decrypt was
saying private schmidt is being sent to
somewhere else
first reaction is who's private schmidt
what do we know about him let's go and
have a look at the card index
so eventually and it had to be done very
quickly because time was of the essence
in this
intelligence digests were prepared
the really hot stuff the top top top
secret stuff they're really crucial
things were sent off to a man called rv
jones in whitehall who was in direct he
was
churchill's intelligence man and passed
all of this stuff onto him
in terms of the armed forces and how
they got their decrypts and they got out
to admirals generals and so on
one of the
advantages that bletchley park had right
from the start of the war there was an
insistence that all of the services
would be at bletchley park they could
have their own huts but we were not
having any of this nonsense like they
had in the states about the army's
decree the sorry the navy's decryption
effort it's always the navy had to be
totally separate to everybody else's far
better funded and preferably hundreds of
miles away from what the army was doing
it's not to say that bletchley there
weren't inter-service rivalries there
were
but in the end everybody trusted the man
in the middle the man who decided who
got to know about what was called the
ultra secret and here we have it in his
book freddie had served in the army in
world war one he was 42 when world war
ii started
so as a young man who'd been in the army
who transferred to the air force by
world war ii clearly at his age you're
not going to be put up in fighter
airplanes but he became basically chief
of the air department of the secret
intelligence service
and he did a superb job because um
he had to be trusted by the other
services to say who was high enough up
the chain to be entrusted with knowing
that decryption was going on in
bletchley park
and who had to be kept out of the
picture
because always as you can imagine the
idea was to pass off the intelligence
gained somehow having been acquired from
another source and not of course from
decryption so freddie walked around in a
bomber jacket and i'm assured by my dad
was a complete um
uh how shall we say personality and went
round and uh glad-handed everybody and
clearly did a superb job and freddie was
in charge of what were called special
liaison units these were people posted
out to raf army naval stations to act as
a liaison between the bletchley park mob
and the commanders who really needed
this intelligence
so the bletchley park
linguists intelligence officers and so
on prepared agreed summaries at the end
of every day they were sent out over
secure landlines were these summaries
but there was no way you were going to
trust that
they were sent out encrypted over secure
landlines
as a result of encountering the enigma
the
allies or rather the the staff at
bletchley park principally i think had
come up with their military colleagues
with the idea of having a better enigma
a much better and more secure machine
they came up with a type x it was an
enigma but without the flaws it was
bigger better faster and above all it
would sometimes encrypt a letter to
itself so it avoided the fatal flaw the
summaries were encrypted using type x
and sent out over secure landlines if
you were taken on by freddie to do this
work it didn't matter if you were only a
leading aircraftman mark ii as my dad
was
if you were taken on to do the work you
immediately got promoted to flight
sergeant my dad's proud portrait of
himself taken i think in 1943 in the
town in yorkshire where we lived at the
time in harrogate and there he is if you
look on the right of the picture you can
see his flight sergeant stripes so that
pretty well enables me to date it he was
stationed up in the northwest of england
at a near a town called carlisle
that's an raf base called annan almost
you could tell he was the right
candidate for this sort of thing because
he taught himself shorthand when he was
a teenager he loved the idea of secret
writing and he also taught himself to
type touch typing nowadays with computer
keyboards some of us i've never got
around to it i've also taught ourselves
touch typing so it might be commonplace
today but in early 1943 a circle would
come around saying all those who would
like to be interested in better paid
work are invited to come and take an
intelligence test and part of that
intelligence test would be a crossword
puzzle so my dad had a go at it i think
it was a telegraph concise crossword and
you weren't given very long to do it but
he must have done well enough
because eventually the call came to
report to london
and
he reported it
to part of the gc and cs uh set up which
wasn't in bletchley park it was
still in london had loads of interviews
loads of further tests and so on
and was eventually told that he'd pass
the tests and that if he accepted the
job offer
he would be
instantly promoted
to a flight sergeant
more money it will be a much more
interesting job and that he will be
helping in some small way to win the war
fine
in the final stages of the interview you
got to meet group captain freddie
himself it was went something like this
and my dad said yes it did it went just
like that you get called in braille said
i have to congratulate you you've passed
all our tests all this you know
what i'm now about to reveal to you is
the biggest secret of the war
if you ever reveal a word of this this
is what will happen to you presses a
button on his desk
in comes the staff sergeant
with the service revolver
fortunately not loaded but i don't know
my dad knew that at the time pointed us
at my dad's head and just went click he
said yes
we will kill you if you reveal this
secret and of course
as freddie says in the interview well
reduce them to jelly you know yes it did
my dad's was always a quiet and rather
reserved chap and honestly i i do
believe in some ways it made him
slightly more introverted it wasn't that
he wasn't a charming chap and a great
dad he was but i think like many people
related to this work in the war they
were worried all the time that not
deliberately but just by accident
something they said might give the game
away he really really worried about it i
can understand that now
so anyway we went on on this basis of
what did you do in the war dad sorry son
i can't tell you for many many years
afterwards
and
suddenly
all of a sudden i didn't even know about
freddie winterbottom
my dad in the early 70s
phones me up i was in nottingham at the
time my dad said look at this you
remember that i told you how top secret
this was
he said the trap who personally
threatened me with instant death if i
ever revealed a word of this i was not
going to publish the book on it i can't
believe it the ultra secret we weren't
even supposed to say the word ultra
that's how secret it was isn't it
so i thought
heavens
so i said come on then dad tell me all
about it
um afterwards i found out that it wasn't
just freddie being a maverick although
he was
the reason that he got permission to
publish this and he did get permission
was something like the following
the
winston churchills and the top browsing
whitehall of this world wanted to keep
bletchley's stuff secret preferably for
a hundred years
their american colleagues who were
building all these bombs and enigmas and
replicas and joining us oh come on you
cannot keep the lid on it for that long
it'll become an old hat now come on you
know you guys you've got like a 25 or a
30 year rule and and still whitehorse
saying not nearly long enough we need
far longer and remember say look we are
far better with this stuff than you are
i don't think they quite had a freedom
of information act but they made it very
clear that they were going to tell at
least some of the story after 30 years
around about 1974
all of a sudden freddie who'd wanted to
publish a book had been told resolutely
no suddenly gets the go-ahead
i think i'm cynical about this that some
of the top brass had worked out that
freddie's story about yes it's top
secret there's all these buffins doing
this wonderful stuff but i don't know
the details but i will tell you how i
recruited my cypher sergeants absolutely
ideal no technicalities involved and yet
it sent a clear signal across the
atlantic this is our show we're going to
get in first you know
um so that's why freddie went on a book
tour and cheerfully would um sign books
so my dad went up after the talk
introduced himself it was the first time
he met freddie since he was threatened
with instant death i think and as you
can see on the description here
freddie's wonderful handwriting you know
what does it say f brailsford one of the
silent men signed fw winterbottom
troubles is writing so bad my dad has
had to write the word silent so that we
can decrypt the signature as it were as
far as my dad was concerned what then
followed was really
interesting
glamorous in some ways but full of cold
and muddy tents at the same time one of
his first postings was in late 1943 was
to admiral burt ramsey's operation at
portsmouth this later merged in with a
much bigger operation because those of
you of an older generation out there
will know
that it was decided in the lead-up to
d-day in 1944 that the supreme commander
would of course have to be an american
since they were putting in the great
majority of men materiel and so on
effectively my dad was attached as a
part of this huge encampment of people
right next door to eisenhower's
headquarters
and what would happen every day is that
he would at a certain time
connect his type x machine to the secure
landline from bletchley park he would
get over the teleprinter landline the
summary suitably encrypted he would set
up his type x machine he would then go
with the decrypt off to
not eisenhorn himself but a senior
intelligence officer
who freddie had agreed was senior enough
to be in on the ultra secrets and know
all about this
and i think what had to happen i'm not
sure was that the
decrypt in some way i'm not sure the
details was
then transcribed to a one-time pad as it
was called you know a cipher mechanism
that's used once only taken into
eisenhower deciphered in front of him
you know strong security at all stages
eventually once the message about this
crucial thing about i don't know timing
of d-day or whatever
was uh got through
the intelligence officer would come back
shake my dad by the hand and the two of
them had to solemnly burn all of the
transcripts and stir the ashes and throw
them away and all this it was almost a
ritual my dad said that you had to go
through to destroy the evidence
and i said well what were there any
problems and he said well apart from not
being able to sleep in the tents and the
constant buzz of airplanes taking off
and so on the biggest problem were
people both on the american and the
english sides who were fairly senior but
not senior enough jumping up and down
and starting to say come over here
brailsford anything you show to those
americans you show to me and having to
show them your top secret orders that
said that wasn't true
and then watching in great glee as a u.s
england shouting match broke out the
further adventures involved having to
follow behind
eisenhower's headquarters
uh set up a little bit
uh in late 1944 across into northern
france uh of course you needed the
intelligence operation right behind the
leaders
at the same time church was completely
and totally paranoid about not wanting
the slus and the type x machinery to get
too close to berlin
because what church was worried about
and it's even mentioned in the imitation
game quite correctly churchill was
paranoid not so much about the germans
but about the russians getting hold of
this technology i think my dad was
demobilized
at ve day
which is mentioned in
freddy's book
i think he was in the ardennes in
belgium at the time
and everything went very smoothly till
the end of the war but that's just
part of the story and i suppose my my
friends and so on say to me well
this is amazing you know your dad was
one of these cypher sergeants
do you think it's got anything to do
with you being interested in puzzles and
sudoku's and computer science i have not
the slightest doubt it is if you believe
in genetics at all i now look back at
what my dear dad was interested in and
how he really loved to have
explained to him everything i was doing
more or less as far as he could follow
it
he's not in any way up in the
genius category not at all but he was he
had that talent for taking immense pains
about things and plodding on forever
till he understood it and was very
methodical and all that so yeah i think
it was inevitable folks that's probably
a large part of the reason why i turned
out to be a computer scientist
mingus who features in the imitation
game eventually became the person we all
know as m the head of mi6 and james bond
except that inside ml6 is not called m
is called c
so just remember when you see the
imitation game the person mingus who's
so helpful to the decryption effort is
actually the prototype
head of mi6